hey this is presh tall Walker if someone
asks hey can you tell me the average of
the numbers a mathematician might
jokingly say which mean do you mean most
people are referring to the arithmetic
mean which is the most common simple
average but in some applications other
means may be more appropriate for
example the geometric mean is useful to
calculate the average annual growth rate
and it's used in economics for example
then there's the harmonic mean which is
useful to calculate things like the
average speed there's also something
called the root mean square which is
useful in electrical engineering and
it's also called the quadratic mean
interestingly enough there is a
relationship between all of these means
it's abbreviated by their acronym the
RMS am GM and H M inequality this is
useful in math competitions and it's
also useful in theoretical proofs in
this video I'm going to present the
version for two variables because
there's a nice geometric visualization
of it so first let's State it for
positive numbers a and B the largest
quantity will be the root mean square
this is equal to the square root of the
quantity a squared plus B squared all
over 2 this will always be greater than
or equal to a plus B over 2 which is
called the arithmetic mean this will
always be greater than or equal to the
square root of a times B which is the
geometric mean and this will always be
greater than or equal to 2 divided by
the quantity 1 over a plus 1 over B
which is the harmonic mean furthermore
equality holds if and only if a is equal
to B so this seems like an extremely
complicated statement but we'll be able
to demonstrate why this is true
geometrically so let's get started with
the geometric construction we start out
with 1
length of a and another length of B now
we construct a semicircle with diameter
a plus B next we construct a radius of
this semicircle notice it has length
that's half of the diameter therefore it
will be a plus B over 2 which is the
arithmetic mean
now let's construct the root-mean-square
this segment right here is equal to the
length of the radius minus the length of
a this will be B minus a all over 2 now
suppose the vertical radius is
perpendicular to the diameter we now
construct the hypotenuse of this right
triangle using the Pythagorean theorem
we can figure out its length it will be
equal to the root mean square which is
the square root of the quantity a
squared plus B squared all over 2 from
this diagram we can see the
root-mean-square will always be greater
than or equal to the arithmetic mean
because the hypotenuse is never smaller
than one of its legs now let's construct
the geometric mean we'll construct a
perpendicular where the two line
segments meet now a triangle inscribed
in a semicircle is always a right
triangle so we've constructed an
altitude on a hypotenuse of a right
triangle using those properties we can
deduce that the length of the red
segment is equal to the square root of a
times B and this is the geometric mean
now let's construct the harmonic mean
but before we do that let's relate the
geometric mean to the arithmetic mean
we'll construct a hypotenuse from the
top of this red line to the center of
the semicircle the hypotenuse is a
radius of the circle so it's length is
equal to the arithmetic mean which is a
plus B over 2 and from this diagram we
can deduce that the arithmetic mean is
always greater than or equal to the
geometric mean
so now let's construct the harmonic mean
well draw an altitude to this hypotenuse
using the properties of an altitude on
hypotenuse we'll try and figure out the
length of this purple segment which
we'll call X so using these similar
triangles we get that the geometric mean
squared is equal to x times the
arithmetic mean we substitute in those
values and then solve for X another way
of writing this is 2 divided by 1 over a
plus 1 over B which is exactly the
harmonic mean so now from this diagram
we can deduce the geometric mean is
always greater than or equal to the
harmonic mean so now let's put all of
these lengths together in the same
diagram we can compare the lengths
geometrically we have that the root mean
square is greater than or equal to the
arithmetic mean we also know the
arithmetic mean is greater than or equal
to the geometric mean and then we have
that the geometric mean is greater than
or equal to the harmonic mean this is
all because the hypotenuse of a right
triangle is greater than or equal to
either of its legs we can combine all of
these inequalities together and we have
the root-mean-square arithmetic mean
geometric mean and harmonic mean
inequality voila
but we want to see what happens if a is
equal to B obviously if a is not equal
to B then we have strict inequalities
because the hypotenuse of a right
triangle is strictly larger than the leg
of its triangle but now what happens if
a is equal to B do we get that all of
these lengths are equal to each other
well let's once again visualize this
geometrically here's an animation of be
approaching a that I made with the
decimals calculator I provided a link to
desmos comm in the video description
let's see what happens as we make the
length of B approach the length of a
notice how all the lengths are
converging to the same value and when B
is equal to a they all are exactly equal
so this illustrates that the
inequalities become equal if a is equal
to B so to put this all together we've
demonstrated the root-mean-square
arithmetic mean geometric mean and
harmonic mean inequality for two
variables an equality holds if and only
if a is equal to B this is the
inequality for two variables but it
actually generalizes to n variables in
the following form this is not easy to
visualize geometrically so I provided a
link to this in the video description
but these inequalities are very useful
in problem solving and pay attention
because they're going to appear and some
of my upcoming videos thanks for
watching this video i post math videos
that can be watched for free with topics
from people around the world because
math is universal if you'd like to help
the cause please subscribe to get the
newest videos and please watch and share
all of mine your decisions videos if you
have a math topic or puzzle you can
email me at presh at mind your decisions
calm as I'm getting so many emails
nowadays I may not be able to reply to
everyone but I'll do my best
if you like this video you can also
check out my books which are linked in
the video description and if you so
choose you can support me on patreon to
help show that math is universal thanks
for watching and thanks for your support